[Applaudissements]
c'était quoi votre plus grand rêve
moi je voulais travailler dans lux et
mon objectif dans la vie dès l'âge de 13
ans c'était d'être accrochez-vous
directeur marketing internationales sur
la région asie-pacifique d'une très
grande marque de luxe française
et ça commence par match
et il ya dix ans j'étais à votre place
dans cet amphithéâtre j'entre l école de
commerce
prêt arrive prêt à atteindre mes rêves
et c'est dans cet objectif que j'ai
agences et toutes mes expériences
professionnelles et personnelles en
première année j'ai eu la chance d'aller
en chine faire mon stage pour découvrir
un peu comment la vie était là bas en
deuxième année je me suis dit j'allais
me sentais un peu plus vert du haut de
gamme perdu produit de la maroquinerie
j'ai la chance d'être le premier
stagiaire la boutique longeant qui
venait d'ouvrir à dijon en tant que
vendeur et développeur de marché chinois
et ça c'était génial parce que ces
expériences et c'était bien réel
le problème c'est que j'arrive à l'école
j'ai envie de m'amuser j'en j'adore
organiser des soirées j'ai envie de
faire plus de soirées
et un jour j'organise une soirée et je
décide de louer une tireuse à bière et
je vais vous raconter comment cette
tireuse à bière petit à petit elle a
changé ma vie
à l'époque on pensait pas que ça coûtait
aussi cher une tireuse à bière et c'est
pour ça que je décide d'appeler une
entreprise un gérant d'une entreprise
qui en joue et je me retrouve le
téléphone a négocié un peu le prix avec
lui et je lui dis qu'il faut absolument
qu'il soit partenaire de cette folie de
soirée qui regroupe des futurs cadres de
l'école commerce de l'école de commerce
de dijon il ya potentiellement de
nombreux futurs clients il faut
absolument que sur sponsors de cette
soirée
en échange on pourrait lui faire mal au
go sa communication tout ce qu'il aura
besoin et en vrai à ce moment là je
l'entends parler et je me dis dans la
tête c'est impossible qu'ils me disent
oui
c'est vrai et là il me dit vas-y chaud
bon en vrai j'abuse un peu il n'a pas
dit je suis chaud il a dit peut-être un
truc du genre ok pourquoi pas assez
intéressant rencontre nous parlons nous
et à cet instant dans ma tête incroyable
c'est en train de se passer parce que
pour moi faire du business ça venait
après le stage après le diplôme c'est
vrai j'étais encore étudiant
finalement on lui fait un flyer une
plaquette de communication ça se passe
trop trop bien et aujourd'hui encore dix
ans plus tard on a pris l'habitude de
louer une tireuse tous les étés c'est
vrai
et cette expérience pour moi c'est un
premier vrai déclic dans le sens où même
en étant étudiant en fait on a des
compétences on a des choses qu'on peut
apporter à des entreprises et les
entreprises en ont besoin et ça c'est
juste génial
quelques mois plus tard j'arrive en
master et là je me prends une claque
parce que c'est extrêmement décevant en
terme de cours on nous rabâche les mêmes
concepts marketing qu'on a déjà vu et
vue c'est très scolaire et académique
c'est théorique
concrètement samsung
et à ce moment-là je me dis que
j'aimerais bien faire quelque chose qui
est un peu plus de sens qu'ils soient
ancrés dans le monde actuel une approche
un peu plus créatives digital c'était
l'essor des réseaux sociaux ont parlé
communication ligne très peu
d'entreprises à ce moment là avait
réellement une belle présence en ligne
je décide de l'inscrire à des coudes à
des cours de code le soir aux bénévoles
en auditeur libre et j'apprends à coder
un petit peu un site internet je me
rends compte que j'aime bien ça c'est
très accessible en fait le code et les
soirs et les week-ends je peaufine et
j'arrive à sortir un site internet sur
lequel je dépose mon cv j'arrive à cause
d un site internet sur lequel je suis à
peu près satisfait et je me dis ok ça
c'est cool j'ai obtenu une nouvelle
compétence comment est ce que je vais
pouvoir arriver à la mettre en pratique
de manière un peu plus opérationnel un
peu plus concrète
est ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé de
consulter les horaires d'une boutique en
ligne
et lorsque vous allez faire du shopping
pour déposer ou retirer un colis par
exemple c'est fermé parce que les
horaires n'étaient pas juste ce n'est
pas ultra frustrant comme sentiment en
vrai c'est extrêmement frustrant alors
ça met la puce à l'oreille je me dis je
vais peut-être commencer par là
peut-être que les commerçants ont besoin
d'être un peu plus d'aidé alors je me
retrouve à faire du porte-à-porte aller
voir des commerçants en leur disant
bonjour génial que vous faites vos
produits ils sont incroyables par contre
pas de site internet vous avez pas titi
commerce sa patte page facebook ni
instagram c'est trop dommage parce que
je suis sûr qu'ils auraient des gens qui
gagnerait à connaître votre produit qui
voudrait acheter ce que vous vendez eh
bien nous on a une équipe de
développeurs et on fait du marketing à
l'école de commerce on peut vous aider à
vous lancer en ligne sur le digital
ça c'était le matin en journée et le
soir quand j'allais en soirée je
demandais à tout le monde mais que tu
fais quoi dans la vie tu sais pas faire
un peu de code toi et tu connais pas
quelqu'un qui pourrait nous faire un
site internet parce qu'en fait là j'ai
plein de clients je suis totalement solo
je m'en sors pas du tout et ils veulent
tous un site internet donc si jamais tu
connais quelqu'un pense à moi j'avais
clairement personne j'avais zéro client
je n'avais aucun contact rien du tout
et un jour je me balade dans le centre
ville de rouen je rends dans une
boutique qui vend des sacs en cuir et je
fais mon pitch habituel à la gérante
et longtemps et elle me regarde avec des
yeux grands comme ça et elle me dit
c'est quoi victoire chiche au
bon en vrai j'abuse encore gl a pas
d'issue chaud c'est vrai elle a dit
plutôt un truc du genre moi j'y crois
beaucoup digital fait moins de vie fait
moins de vie très bien à ce moment-là je
rencontre une personne qui me dit pas
moi je sais faire des sites internet je
suis châtaignier dans ton projet
pourquoi pas
parfaite amis j'ai juste à connecter les
deux personnes on se met en mode projet
et on y va c'est concret céréales
comment faire de vie alors un devis pour
un site internet prend des photos
retouche photo allez voir le banquier
pour lui dire qu'il faut implémenter le
système de paiement en ligne que je
n'avais pas du tout faire c'est la prs
et je vais facture ce devis 180 euros
c'est pas à grand chose
et la clientèle voit le devis et elle
m'a dit
tu peux me faire un prix
et moi je dis bah ouais t'inquiète pas
je te fais je te fais tout pour 150
euros
à titre informatif aujourd'hui pour le
même projet même pour 3000 euros je
pense qu'on n'irait pas mais c'est pas
grave parce qu'à ce moment là c'est pas
le prix qui compte c'est la réalisation
c'est du concret c'est comment mettre en
ligne cette compétence on veut sortir le
site pour la cliente on veut sortir le
site pour la cliente on n'a jamais sorti
site pour la cliente
on n'a jamais sorti site enfin si on la
fait quelques années plus tard mais ça
c'est une autre histoire
arrive le moment où je dois faire mon
stage de fin d'études est alors dans ces
notions de luxe et cette notion de
digital via une boîte qui me fait rêver
c'est google google parce que j'avais vu
tous les reportages j'avais vu que les
bureaux étaient incroyables et gens qui
bossent les projets salaires
l'incroyable j'ai la chance d'être pris
en stage de fin d'études au bureau de
paris en marketing parfait et c'est
exactement comme ce qu'on voit dans les
films la cantine gratuite à volonté
incroyable les bureaux la salle de sport
ils ont même une piscine à dublin c'est
fou c'est fou et les gens est
extrêmement talentueux et j'adore
j'adore j'adore c'est vraiment comme si
j'avais projeté
on bossait avec l'asie le matin avec
l'europe en journée et le soir les états
unis trop bien sauf que en termes de
marketing je reste un peu frustré parce
que je me rends compte que dans ces
énormes boîtes en fait à notre petit
niveau on n'a pas grande flexibilité et
qu'en réalité tous les projets
stratégiques sont déjà décidées 5 ans 10
ans l avance et que même côté
opérationnel créatifs ont toutes été
régi par des agences donc en fait on
coordonne plus les agences qu'autre
chose je décide de pas forcément
poursuivre en marketing
et c'est à ce moment là qu'on vous
propose un poste de formateur dans le
programme google ateliers numériques et
ça c'était trop bien c'était trop bien
parce que concrètement avec mon binôme
on faisait partie des deux premières
personnes dans toute la france a
sillonné tout le territoire a donné des
conférences en marketing digital dans
une dans une ville différente chaque
semaine c'était trop bien c'était trop
bien parce que c'était déjà gratuit
c'est à dire que rencontrer des
entrepreneurs des étudiants les grands
groupes des gens comme vous et moi et
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur
on a à peu près deux ans on a dû faire
200 villes et personnellement j'ai dû
rencontrer à peu près dix mille
personnes c'est énorme dix mille
personnes on s'en rend même plus compte
aujourd'hui
est typiquement les thèmes sur lesquels
on formait c'était des thèmes parfois
pas trop sexy mais important quand même
le référencement naturel l'analyse de
données la publicité en ligne comment ça
fonctionne comment générer plus de
croissance en ligne en fait
est-ce qu'ils étaient trop bien c'est
systématiquement à chaque fois de
conférence les gens venaient nous voir
et nous poser des questions tiens victor
ça c'est mon site internet qu'est ce que
tu en penses ou encore ses arrières
victor je bosse avec tes al'agence de
communication voici la stratégie
digitale qu'est ce que tu en penses
et concrètement on comprend que la
question sous jacente qui pose c'est
est-ce que oui ou non je m'en faire
entuber
vraiment et au début on bombe apple
torse c'est flatteur c'est bon pour
l'ego on se dit c'est gratifiant
mais au bout de 200 personnes 300
personnes qui pose toujours les mêmes
questions c'est extrêmement frustrant on
se rend compte qu'en fait il ya des
peurs il ya des non-dits adam méfiance
en fer envers ce secteur marketing
digital c'est vrai c'est compliqué il ya
du jargon c'est vrai mais ça c'est
extrêmement frustrant c'est extrêmement
frustrant parce que on est vingt ans
après la génèse de google on est capable
d'emmener des gens dans l'espace sur la
lune par contre en terme de
communication les professionnels
français sont totalement paumées
et à ce moment-là je me dis qu'il faut
changer les choses et on va faire
quelque chose de nouveau
je me tourne vers pierre mon actuel
associé c'est la personne n'a plus qu'à
aller en digital que je connaisse il est
incroyable et je lui dis mais qu à la
fin d'année moi je parle du programme
j'aimerais bien que toi tu démissionnes
de google et kova non on va monter notre
cadeau on va monter une boîte on va
accompagner les gens à notre manière on
va se faire kiffer et on va leur répond
d'une manière beaucoup plus opérationnel
et savait trop bien et pour le
convaincre l'ue et surtout pour qu'on
voit que mes parents pourquoi tu
démissionnes de google et le salaire et
le confort et la mission etc c'est vrai
ça pourquoi eh bien je leur dis
franchement on fait un pari on se donne
un an un an
au mieux si on se plante on aura
démissionné google on a monté notre
boîte n'importe qui dans le monde voudra
nous recruter et au pire en pire ça
marche en fait au pire ça marche on fait
un truc de ouf on vit nos rêves glasgow
et une regarde il dit
mec je suis ultra chaud et lui pour le
coup je ne juge pas il dit vraiment mais
chutera chut on part dans un délire
incroyable mais qu'imagine au bout d'un
an d'un stage d'un mois ce serait ouvre
mais qui imagine on a des bureaux un
jour où l on m a dit goran des piscines
comme google un truc de ouf on part
totalement en live on se lance pierre
démissionné quelques mois plus tard et
là on sera une énorme claque
en trois années dans votre sac parce que
deux mois plus tard on a recruté deux
stagiaires on est quatre on doit prendre
des bureaux et tout le monde à côté nous
dit mais les gars vous êtes complètement
cinglé mais faites pas ça en fait le
prenez pas des bureaux vous allez vous
planter mais on voit le truc qu'on va le
délire
deux mois après on recrute de deux
internats dont un qui a un contrat de
deux ans avec son école donc autant vous
dire qu'à ce moment là le délire de
rester un an c'est totalement tombé à
l'eau et en fait on se rend compte que
petit à petit on a embarqué des gens
dans cette mission de vie qui croit en
nos valeurs et qui croit vraiment en ce
profond changement digital on fait nos
un an pendant le confinement et dans la
foulée
on recrute notre premier cdi qui
s'appelle jérémy et d'ailleurs qui vient
de bsb aujourd'hui ça fait un peu plus
deux ans et c'est une quinzaine de
personnes incroyables qui s'arrache qui
se défonce et qui oeuvrent au quotidien
pour aller réduire cette fracture
numérique en france
alors oui peut-être peut-être
qu'on a réalisé notre rêve ou peut-être
que pas du tout et que demain on va se
réveiller dans un tout autre rêve qui
s'est en tout cas il ya une chose qui
est sûre
c'est que pour nous cette mission cet
adn de vouloir changer les choses a fait
écho à ces thématiques d'aujourd'hui
leed for change et c'est la thématique
également de l'école
on rêve d'un monde où les gens comme
vous et moi comme les entrepreneurs
comme les grands groupes puissent lancer
des projets puissent s'appuyer sur du
digital pour arriver à atteindre leur
rêve et on rêve de ça on reste
profondément d'un changement comme celui
ci alors comment on fait comment on fait
pour casser les codes comment on fait
pour ouvrait dans ce secteur extrêmement
opaque
et bien on fait un nouveau rêve confie
un nouveau rêve
qui constituait de trois autres rêves
qui sont tous intimement liés les uns
avec les autres un peu connus comme dans
inception
et ses rêves ses formes est
accompagnée redonner
forme accompagné redonner forme et parce
que la condition sinequanone chez nous
pour devenir client c'est avant tout
d'acquérir de la connaissance on est des
enfants d'information on veut former nos
clients on veut déjà organisé qui on
refuse aujourd'hui des clients qui ne
veulent pas nous autres aient du temps
pour que les formes et la raison
derrière la rationnelle derrière elle
est simple c'est que si pour x ou y
raison on arrête de bosser avec ses
clients je sais que parce que nous on
les aura formé plus jamais se font
entuber par la presse par leurs
prestataires
ensuite accompagné
accompagner oui mais en capitalisant non
pas sur des contrats long terme en
capitalisant plutôt sur nos clients et
comment on capitalise sur des clients
est bon le fait monter en compétences on
les fait passer d'un niveau un sur dix
novices à 5 sur 10 on les montants
compétences on les forme on les rend
autonome le plus rapidement possible
pour que derrière on les aide à recruter
maintenant on forme leur équipe en
interne pour qu'ils puissent
internaliser ses compétences et qu'on
aille se concentrer sur les tâches à
plus forte valeur ajoutée comme comment
on rentre sur le marché asiatique
comment l'en cette nouvelle gamme de
produits où ce service
et enfin on redonne on redonne en donne
en cours dans les écoles dans les
incubateurs dans des entreprises et le
type de cours condensait nier qu'on
donne aux étudiants c'est exactement le
même type de cours que nous on aurait
qui fait avoir à votre place à la place
des étudiants on leur apprend à créer
des sites internet on leur apprend à
vendre en ligne la publicité google
facebook et c est ce que google nous
écoute on répond à des questions comme
ça
et pourquoi en fait on fait parce qu'on
se dit clairement donné lors que ces
personnes là elles iront en entretien
devant harrach où elles seront dans leur
premier job les blazers ont mouillé la
chemise l ombre elles ont réellement
testé la publicité à seront comment
faire et elles pourront elles mêmes
changer ce système de l'intérieur et
c'est comme ça qu'on redonne confiance à
la fois l'école aux entreprises aux
étudiants c'est comme ça qu'on redonne
confiance dans le digital
alors vous souvenez du petit garçon de
13 ans qui voulait absolument travailler
dans le luxe
parfois je me dis qu'on y est
ça luxe aujourd'hui pour moi d'avoir la
chance de travailler des gens
incroyables au quotidien c'est un luxe
de pouvoir choisir ses clients
l'émission sur lesquelles on souhaite
travailler c de pouvoir entreprendre un
autre manière les it for child
sa lutte de pouvoir redonner partager
alors merci merci à l'école qui nous
exposent à de l'ambition merci à cette
fameuse tireuse à bière qui prouve
qu'ils procurent à déclic merci à toutes
les personnes dont je croise le chemin
en soirée il faut faire des soirées fait
plus de soirée ça provoque des
opportunités c'est vrai c'est vrai et
merci à toutes les personnes au
quotidien qui nous accompagnent dans
cette mission de ville qui croient dans
ce qu'on fait l'équipe les partenaires
les clients parce que si c'est pas
simple tous les jours au quotidien c'est
pas rose s'est pas vraiment facile
aujourd'hui dix ans plus tard je réalise
que j'ai le luxe et la chance
d'entreprendre mes rêves
et parce que chacun devrait pouvoir
avoir le luxe et la chance
d'entreprendre ses rêves souvenez vous
d'une chose au pire ça marche
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]